What we're showing here is
a picture of high magnification,
probably a electron micrograph,
then pseudo colored, of your retina.
And you can see that retina is
made up of two kinds of receptors
called rods and cones, and we'll talk
more about the differences between them
when we do the human
anatomy conversation.
But today,
all we're going to talk about is cones.
And in particular, there are several
million cones in the retina.
They tend to be focused more or grouped
more in the, near the fovea, the middle.
They're responsible for
the high-resolution imagery.
That is your ability to see very
sort of with a good resolution at
the center of your visual field.
And most importantly, for
today's conversation,
it's your cones that discriminate color.
That is that they're sensitive
to different wavelengths, and
your, your visual system uses
the outputs of the cones,
processed through a variety
of channels to see color.
And particularly there are three
types of cones that are called red,
green, and blue.
That's not really quite correct,
you'll see why in a minute.
They really should be called long,
medium, and short.
And you'll also see it's written here
that the vast majority of them are red
and green and a very small
percentage of them are blue.
All right.
So, this is a graph of the sensitivity
of each of these three types of cones,
roughly red, green and blue, in terms of
how responsive they are as a function of
a single band of wavelength of light.
So here you see the wavelength of
the light expressed in nanometers, and
you can see that there's
one channel right here that
starts at the longer range and
peaks somewhere around there.
And then there's another one that's
called green even though it's
really just offset
a little bit from that.
And then finally,
what's called the blue,
which is really the short
wavelength cone.
If you were to make a picture of sort
of the retinal mosaic and you colored
the cones, what you'd see would be
a picture that looks kind of like this.
You'll notice that in the middle,
there's hardly any blue cones at all and
there's some more of them out here,
all right.
But basically almost all of the cones
that are used are in the red and green.
And the the blue is really just
there for a little bit of coverage.
And yet we see color very, very well.